[Music]
so
all of you both of us okay
so have you been covering its press
conferences in here
so you're going to have to work with
them so that you're not perfect six feet
you know blah blah blah yeah so we got
to make sure that still the press
photographers are in
sure uh
you're going to have to you're doing
something today yes and just going too
close to this person
i am voting for bear today
uh can you accept that anything you have
to be lower
sorry who are you at the new york times
are you one of the
poor people are just gonna attend this
today and where do you go
different new york times reporter who
thought i could hop in
you'll have to wait outside all the
seats
yeah so this has been having a whole
ton of interest so there have been seats
available but you're going to have to
wait outside
until they're established and then if
there's something open i will like
you know you're behind this gentlemen
i don't want anybody no there's nobody
feeling me
if they don't show we'll let people in
okay
so you should just wait six feet apart
in math i'm gonna do it right here
right yeah as long as you got lunch i
did i was able to eat lunch thank you
very much i appreciate your concern
you see i was in line and then someone
from the press photographer's
pharmaceutical texted me
made me get out of line and then the
line only got longer
that delayed my lunch and you see i was
already angry the
person who texted the brush target
gallery
so you can go and in the hallways they
need to be six feet apart yeah
so you can go i think that middle spot
is open or whatever
i can get five minutes okay you do get
money right here
whatever you guys want to do
[Music]
so what do you guys want to do so you
guys do you guys mind coming in
after they leave or
so yeah because we can't have any more
than five photographers
and i need to get the pressing here
first um
matt i'm going to be in here two minutes
yeah literally
if you don't mind to the
that way to the left in that hallway
play's out there
what's in the hallway full time
before who's the other time tom bradley
i still got six minutes oh yeah
he's at school come on
um
someone sent me a picture of starburst
in a cup with a price on it breakfast
yeah that was probably tesla's test as
yesterday maybe
i mean like there's a whole raccoon yeah
in dirksen that's disgusting
just science they're individually
wrapped but they have like warm cups of
water to have
chocolate like to wash it down
gravy
i should walk across the stage and take
his place
yeah i just want these two and then
then really i'm really
let's go back right in between those two
chairs alan
oh i'm kelly thank you jason thank you
yeah
where is
photographers have cameras really
you want to go there
excuse me
she will wreck you i know i don't mess
with that i'm so
awesome
so i mess with the ball get the horns
could you get people have people after
the beat yesterday
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
um
my
thank you
two minutes
okay
yes
oh
i got this
please
he just went yeah
thank you
hi guys what's up
hmm
okay good afternoon everyone thank you
for coming i'm proud to be joined
by senators wyden and hirono and murphy
and we want to talk before we talk about
what's at stake for millions of
americans i want to touch on last
night's debate
now we've seen president trump melt down
when confronted with
facts many times but his obscene
performance that's what it was a
performance not a debate
and it was extremely filled with
right wing bile that included lie after
lie after lie
president trump insulted the vice
president's deceased son
a veteran and public servant and tried
to smear his living one
he gave a fringe white supremacist group
a new rallying cry
stand back and stand by was immediately
embraced by the proud boys it's on their
website
appalling and the president of the
united states
capped off the night by casting doubt on
our
elections tarnishing our democracy
shakespeare said it best
president trump's debate performance in
the words of macbeth
was a tale told by an idiot
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing
let me say that again because
shakespeare even though he lived 400-400
500 years well 450 years earlier
described it best a tale told by an
idiot
full of sound and fury signifying
nothing
it's a disgrace and it is unfathomable
to me that senate republicans so many
wouldn't denounce the lies we heard last
night
and call on president trump to stop
fueling the hatred and racism
and stop so selling dee doubt in our
elections
and yet senate republicans are doing
trump's bidding
by rushing through a supreme court
nominee merely days before a national
election
but what really worries the american
people is why senate republicans are
rushing
to put their health care at risk
leader mcconnell has spent this week
trying to cover up the fact
that president trump his party and their
supreme court nominee
all want to overturn the aca leader
mcconnell mocked the idea
that a far-right supreme court majority
is a threat to the aca
and that judge barrett's judicial
philosophy would even play a part in
that
but president trump and senate
republicans have made clear for years
that repealing the aca is their top
priority
there's no hiding from their record they
want the supreme court to do what they
dare wouldn't try again to do on the
senate floor
judge barrett's record is clear she has
publicly criticized justice roberts for
upholding the aca
she has written that the supreme court
quote
would have had to invalidate unquote the
law
if it read the statute the way she does
our job our job is to make sure the
american people understand what's at
stake here
on sunday i stood with new yorkers whose
children have pre-existing conditions
a family with a little girl emily was
afraid
of what a court decision striking down
aca would mean for emily's insurance
and there are millions of emilies and
families like emily's
across the country so let's be clear
a vote to confirm judge amy coney
barrett
is a vote to terminate health care
coverage and protections
for hundreds of millions of americans
during a global pandemic no nonetheless
that is why i filed a procedural motion
that will set up a vote on a bill that
would protect the health care of
hundreds of millions of americans
and prevent efforts by the department of
justice
to advocate that courts strike down the
aca
so as soon as tomorrow leader mcconnell
and all my republican colleagues will
have an opportunity to set the record
straight with their vote
do they support a bill to protect
americans with pre-existing conditions
or will they go along with president
trump's plan
to let the unelected supreme court tear
away those protections
that help so many americans now
i'm gonna have to turn i'm gonna with
the ex with the okay of my two other
colleagues
i'm gonna have to turn it over to
senator murphy because he's heading to
the floor to speak on this very topic
senator murphy
thank you very much leader schumer and i
thank the
indulgence of my colleagues listen
this couldn't be any clearer president
trump has made it clear since the 2016
campaign that he is only going to
nominate judges to the supreme court who
will invalidate
the entirety of the affordable care act
he spent all of his first year in office
trying to get the congress
to repeal the affordable care act and he
couldn't do it
and so he joined with republicans
attorney general all
across the country in order to file a
lawsuit
that would do the job that congress
wouldn't and couldn't
taking away insurance from 23 million
americans and raising rates on 130
million others
who have pre-existing conditions a new
pre-existing condition in this country
is covid
now we know today that 44 000 people
are being reported as having coveted on
a daily basis but because this president
doesn't believe in testing
because he is implementing a plan to
test less people rather than more
we know that number is far under
reporting
the total number of cases it is likely
that every single day there are hundreds
of thousands of people
in this country who are becoming covid
positive
and what we are learning about kovid is
so so
troubling dr fauci told the senate
health committee upon which i sit last
week that scientists are finding
that individuals who have recovered from
the infection
now have fatigue muscle pain fever
problems with their neurological system
cognitive abnormalities
just like the such as the inability to
concentrate
he also noted a study that found that
sixty to seventy percent of coveted
positive people including those who are
asymptomatic have indications of
inflammatory disease
of the heart what does this all mean
this means that there is no
question about it covid whether you are
symptomatic or not
is going to be a pre-existing condition
and if insurance
companies can discriminate against
people with pre-existing conditions
then if you have ever had covet whether
you knew it or not
you are either not going to be able to
get insurance ever
again or you are going to be charged so
much
that it is unaffordable this is the
question that senate republicans are
faced with
over the course of the next few weeks if
they vote for judge amy coney barrett
they are going to assure that everybody
in this country with covid
is going to either have insurance
unavailable to them in the future
or going to be charged so much that they
can't ever
afford it covet is a pre-existing
condition now
there are 23 million americans many of
which you
won't have covid who aren't going to be
able to get insurance because they were
allowed on the aca for it
all sorts of other diseases and viruses
and diagnoses
will now be available for higher rates
to the insurance companies
but i wanted to spend my time talking
about this
very specific issue if covert becomes an
existing condition you can't get
insurance
that means you can't get access to
paying for
the treatments you might have limited
access to vaccines
and therapies it becomes a humanitarian
catastrophe those are the stakes in
front of us over the course of the next
several uh days and weeks especially
for people who have had the coven 19
diagnosis
thank you senator murphy senator wyden
thank you um thank you mr leader and
good to be with our our
our colleagues just a quick comment
about last uh
last night um donald trump's claim
last night that he had lowered
prescription drug
prices for americans is in my view
deserving of unlimited numbers of
pinocchios
for example he claimed last night
that he had implemented a strategy
to get tough with the fact that
all the brakes seemed to go to foreign
countries
the finance committee found it for the
same drug
foreigners were paying a lot less than
americans so
donald trump said last night that he had
implemented a most favored nations
policy that would radically
lower prices and this morning health
experts said
that was just untrue just
factually untrue so i appreciate the
leaders scheduling this to give us a
chance to zero in on health care
questions and i want to pick up on my
colleague's point about the affordable
care act
the fact is if donald trump wins in this
case
millions of senior citizens are going to
pay
a lot more for health care
that is a lot worse and let me give you
some examples
first americans who are 55 or 60
and count on private insurance private
insurance
for healthcare are going to be in for a
nightmare
and here for example we might be talking
about an elderly widow
and that elderly widow is already
walking on an economic tightrope
balancing the food bill against the fuel
bill and the fuel bill against the rent
bill
and as senator murphy said we're already
concerned about the prospect
of that person being at high risk
for covid and the consequences that they
would be facing
so this idea of an age tax where you
basically get hammered
just because you're 55 is something that
we
senate democrats disagree with
significantly
second i mentioned the prescription drug
issue there's a problem for seniors
specifically
if trump wins in court seniors are going
to face
a reopening of what's called the
doughnut hole
which is a really byzantine deal but
from c
to shining c what it means for seniors
and this goes back to my days with the
gray panthers they're going to pay a lot
more for their medicine
period full stop finally
we need to talk for just a moment about
medicare which i know
is going to keep coming up in the days
ahead
medicare is heading towards real
financial
problems including the possibility of
insolvency
in just three years because of the
damage
donald trump has done to the economy
the aca lawsuit could make it even worse
so you can't trust donald trump
to protect medicare so we senate
democrats are going to protect
medicare from donald trump and
there are a whole host of issues that
are going to be debated
and i'm sure you're going to have some
questions but nowhere
are the differences more clear than
our policies towards protecting the
rights of vulnerable older people
and what donald trump has laid out and
for example
last night his claims about prescription
drugs
were just right out of fantasyland
and we can get you that information that
backs that up thank you leader
senator
well the clear and present danger of
this nominee to the supreme court is
truly the elimination of the affordable
care act and you've already heard from
my colleagues what that would mean
and that's what we need to do to convey
to the american people
that their health care is at risk with
this nominee
there are so many groups that will be
particularly at risk of course the
seniors
but another group that is at risk would
be the our minority communities
i know you've covered stories of
minority communities and
the fact that so many of them are in the
essential worker category
a lot of them live in multi-generational
households
they are much more likely to have
pre-existing conditions so
this is a vulnerable group of people and
what's really more than appalling
is so many of us have been calling on
president trump
to use the defense production act to
peas manufactured to have ventilators
but you know what he uses
the defense production act to force
a group of people back to work these are
all the people working
in our meat packing plants many of them
most of them are minority people and for
me in hawaii i'm particularly aware
that kofa citizens are very much
working in these meat packing plants and
over 42 000
of all these other people working in
meatpacking class have you ever been
to a meatpacking plant is that a place
that that would be conducive to our
health
so 42 000 people have already been
tested i have tested positive
and me packing plants and 200 of them
have already died
and so he uses the defense production
act
to force these people
to be exposed to
covet this is how much the president
cares
about our health care and yes
you know what the hundred million people
in our country who have preexisting
conditions and i bet you
most of the people here have
pre-existing conditions i certainly do
add to that
the seven million who have tested
positive with many more out there
who will test positive for covet add
them
to the list of people with pre-existing
conditions
the elimination the striking down of the
affordable care act
because amy barrett is going to be on
the court just in time
november 10th to hear the affordable
care act case
will mean that families will be sitting
around their dining tables
with no affordable care act to help them
they're trying to figure out how the
heck they're going to access
the healthcare care that they need this
is this is real
and this is why healthcare is the number
one issue
for everyone in our country except
possibly
the very rich people who got the benefit
of the 1.5 trillion in tax cuts
that president trump pushed through
thank you
we're ready for questions
yes thank you um
republican specifically a majority of
the women in their
conference came out today to celebrate
the barrett nomination
specifically um as her status as a mom
with
school-aged children trying to frame
that as a new dimension
for feminism what is your response to
that particular
angle from from republicans on the
nomination
look at her record her record what she
believes in
in terms of um in terms of aca
you get rid of aca you take loads of
protections away from women's health
you look at her record on the right to
choose which a vast majority of
americans want to
maintain roe v wade and you just see
that her record
is really against what women in america
need and want do you want to follow up
to maisie
it's very clear what her position is on
the affordable care act that is why
she's being pushed
in time to be sitting in the court
november 10th
this is not a coincidence getting rid of
the aca is the number one priority for
president trump and also for the
republicans so that is what's going to
happen why don't we just recognize
what is going on and the the american
people need to hold
all the republicans who vote for this
person
accountable for getting rid of their
health care
yes humor government funding expires
tonight
at midnight the senate hasn't passed the
cr yet when is that going to happen and
are you aware of a reason that hasn't
happened yet i think it will happen in
the next few hours
the house sent us over there bill and um
cloture was last night motion to proceed
was before that
and so we'll vote on it today with
enough time to make sure that the
government stays open
yes senator um i have a question for you
about climate change
sure um as you know vice president joe
biden former vice president
the most ambitious climate change plan
ever put forward by a presidential
candidate two trillion dollars
in spending senate democrats have put
forth also a very ambitious plan that
includes explicitly
passing some kind of carbon price house
democrats have also put
a very ambitious plan forward even if
democrats gain the white house and
the senate you won't have a
filibuster-proof majority
of all of these sweeping ambitious
proposals how does any of this
actually get through and what could
actually get through the senate and i
have a follow-up for all three of you
which is
can each of you tell me where you stand
um on the possibility of eliminating the
filibuster
well to answer the second question first
as i've said before
we first have to elect a majority if we
don't elect a majority
we won't even be discussing it but if we
do elect a majority we'll all get
together and everything
will be on the table nothing will be off
the table on climate
the bottom line is we are looking
already
at ways we can get comprehensive climate
legislation done
and there are a variety of different
ways and we're exploring all of them it
is one of our highest priorities
and we are going to get something very
strong and bold done
and are you talking now with the biden
campaign about what a senate strategy
would look like for that
uh we we are talking with lots of
different people in the other two
senators if you can say where you are on
ending a filibuster
my position is the same as the leader's
position
on filibuster you know there was a time
when i did not support a
filibuster change because the filibuster
is supposed to protect the voice of the
minorities
we're in the minority i don't think
we're our voices are being protected
so i'm open to that discussion but it
won't happen unless the
democrats take back the senate right and
we're we're making it very clear
there are a whole host of issues that
you're going to have to deal with next
year
we're talking about a threat right now
i just went through for example
the fable donald trump is telling about
lowering prescription drug prices he
claimed last night that prices are going
to be going down
80 to 90 percent under his leadership
there are no senior citizens i've met
the last few weeks in oregon
who say oh my goodness ron i'm so glad
my prescription drug prices are going
down
so we are dealing with a threat right
now to the most vulnerable
you know americans i will just tell you
you asked about
the vice president we on the finance
committee have been
talking nonstop for years about this
tale
of two tax codes one set of breaks for
the people at the top
another for a firefighter we learned
just the last couple days about what
that system
means in the new york times expose on
the tax returns
and the vice president to his credit
specifically picked up on the kind of
language that finance democrats are
talking about
where you have to give a fair shake to
people who work
for a wage and not just give all the
breaks to the people who make their
money on wealth
one other thing i'd add to your question
the proposal that i made clean cars for
america which gets
all uh internal combustion cars off the
road by 2040
is part of the biden platform which
shows you how well we're working
together
yes uh the commission on presidential
debates uh
has come out and said that they're
considering changes to the format of the
next two debates i'm just wondering
uh for all of you if there's anything
specific that you'd like to see
changed uh in the next two debates well
i'd say two things
i'd say three things first
unless he's trying to lose i don't think
donald trump should want to debate joe
biden again
second i would say maybe we should give
the moderator a mute button
given how president trump just
interrupts it will and the bottom line
is
donald trump doesn't follow the rules
the commission's got to get a lot
tougher when debate participants don't
follow the rules
okay uh
there are a number of democrat senators
that have said that they're not going to
meet with judge barrett i believe
you've also said that um do you think
that uh
you are in doing that even in protests
missing an opportunity
potentially to vet her on information
that may be
valuable to the public yes we know her
views she's totally opposed to the aca
she's totally opposed to roe v wade on
so many other issues
she said she's following scalia's
philosophy
i think that she is so far away from
where america should be
that no discussion will change any of
that
i said on the judiciary committee i am
one of the members who will not be
meeting with her
and i have said that when the president
accords american people the courtesy
of not lying to us every single day
including during
a debate last night i will extend the
courtesy to meet with his nominee for a
lifetime appointment
who will start by taking away our health
care and then moving on to eliminating a
woman's right to choose
thanks everybody
yes i'll be attending the hearing
specifically about her uh there's been a
report of her connection to a fake group
called
uh people's friends her faith is
irrelevant but what's relevant is that
what the real issue is whether they're
posting abuse
can be separated from her ability to
make
objective fair decisions with their
lifetime fighters do you don't think
that books could come up at all
thank you
[Music]
i know
um
oh
comedy